I'm Levy Rosman chess educator YouTuber
and author let's answer some of your
questions from the internet this is
chess
[Music]
support at manos2 asks do chess players
trash talk that way this game would be
more fun you can't talk to your opponent
during a chess game period so you
definitely can't Trash Talk an opponent
during a chess game but outside of it oh
it's some of the best passive aggressive
soap opera drama you can possibly
imagine now that we have a young Master
like Hans Neeman who despite his
checkered pass no pun intended will
actually go out of his way to Trash Talk
other people and have more eyeballs on
the game so uh yes but also no at Anna
cramling what you got Anna for this
video says is there any more satisfying
Checkmate than this one first of all hi
Anna second of all yes obviously
probably the most satisfying Checkmate
in all of Chess is smothered mate when
an opponent's king is stuck on the edge
of the board Boxed In by his own pieces
and you use this Knight and you Gallop
into the position and the king is
smothered in the corner by his own Army
while this Knight attacks and there's
nothing that you can do at Keen chess
asks was the Hans nean Magnus Carlson
cheating controversy good publicity for
chess what would you make of the drama
overall it was a net positive for chess
there was a massive controversy between
Magnus Carlson and Hans demon where the
young Grandmaster from the United States
defeated the world champion and Magnus
withdrew from the tournament basically
doing everything but directly accusing
Hans of Foul Play millions of people
around the globe started thinking of
Chess they were hearing all of these
ridiculous headlines but at the end of
the day it just sparked their interest
in the game itself at Neo fight 78 asks
okay chess peeps what's the opening or
variation that's the most fun for you to
play one of my favorite variations to
play is when I'm playing with the white
pieces and I open with the King's Pawn
E4 and black responds with C5 which is
the Sicilian Defense it's the most
popular and combative opening for black
black fighting for the center with a
flank Pawn a pawn that's not one of the
two Center pawns and now I will play
What's called a delayed Wing Gambit I
would go Pawn to A3 and the idea here is
very very sneaky you basically want to
give up this Pawn so black is going to
take it and then you are going to take
back now black is going to say wow what
a dummy I just won that pawn now I have
an extra pawn and then you start kicking
out the Knight and you get this massive
Center you have a lot of Pawns in the
center you can even plug another one in
and then you can use all of this open
space for your pieces and a lot of
players get overwhelmed in this position
find a chess opening or variation that
you like that you understand that gets
you to a position where you know the
plans better than your opponent at Eric
Farley 1 asks how does the ELO rating
work I'm intrigued and ELO is the number
which quantifies your skill level it's
not an acronym the first letter is a
capital E and then it goes l o and the
way ELO works is that it goes up and
down or stays the same depending on your
results if you're rated 1,200 and you
play a 1,100 you will gain a certain
amount of points if you win but your
opponent will actually gain slightly
more because they're beating somebody
with a higher ELO the minimum ELO to
qualify for grandmas is
2,500 so an over theboard live chess the
highest ever ELO achieved is by Magnus
Carlson but online stockfish which is
the strongest chess AI in the world is
estimated to be around 3,600 at my Peak
I was 2, 430 then I lost to a bunch of
9-year-olds at Johnny cpem asks how hard
would Kaaba Blanca be to beat with
modern preparation tools at his disposal
how good would Cupa Blanca be with
modern
preparation ridiculously good probably
the world chess champion Jose rul
capablanca was one of the best chess
players of his generation he was a
fantastic positional player he was an
expert endgame player as well the only
thing that he didn't do was live in the
modern Century in the age of computers
he managed to do all of that with chess
being on paperback modern preparation
tools are just a complete GameChanger
they allow you to analyze positions for
1520 moves in advance the information
Gap from 1920 1930 to nowadays is just
absolutely absurd an 11-year-old now
with modern preparation tools could
probably beat capablanca in a match just
on the information that is available to
the 11-year-old that capablanca in the
1920s and 30s would not know at honor R
Singh asks what is going on in your mind
when you have to play your next move
like what is your mind processing
combinations simulations it's a great
question Jose Raul capano said I only
think of one move at a time and it's the
best move chess is all pattern
recognition most experienced chess
players have studied a lot they have
done thousands of Chess puzzles so I
might be remembering Something In My
Memory Palace I might be remembering
there was this game played in 2012
between grandm a Grandmaster B in this
city he was wearing a blue shirt and in
that game he played this the more you
play chess and the more you study that
is how you are going to figure out some
of these good moves or an evaluation of
a position at your bud Josh asks do old
people still play chess in Parks what
parks do you have to be old to play I
want to play chess in the park there is
no minimum age requirement to play Chess
at your local public park but
historically chess has been asso
assciated with old guys at the park when
I was 5 or 6 years old my grandparents
in Brooklyn would walk me to the park
where local 70-year-old men would sit
there squabbling a lot of Park chess
players are actually really good the
average Park chess player in Union
Square Park or Washington Square Park is
better than you watching this right now
so go play against them many of them are
very very friendly they will give you
some pointers and at least here in New
York City it's customary to throw them
like3 or $5 for a game at 7 loano asks
hey Siri how much do chess players make
chess players make exactly what they win
in tournaments nowadays in 2023 there's
also things like endorsement deals
Magnus Carlson is famously sponsored by
Puma MasterCard you can also get invited
to paid corporate or speaking
engagements which a lot of them do
because a lot of people respect chess
players now so it used to be that if you
were outside of the top 20 grand Masters
in the world I'm not even sure you would
break six figures on a good year if
you're you're also traveling the world
constantly playing tournaments and
you're just not succeeding there is so
much more pressure you're probably
losing money in a calendar year at
McKenzie Weber 3 says learning how to
program has changed my perspective on a
lot of things how does a chess bot able
to analyze an entire game and point out
which moves are the best that's so wild
chess Bots have been better than human
beings for something like 30 years chess
Bots like stockfish Leela Alpha zero use
really really
ridiculously powerful servers and they
can analyze tens of millions of
positions every single second what they
do is then they go out into the future
4050 moves in many many different
branches and they come right back and
they evaluate what a move would do
depending on what's out there in the
future _
neore fanore that's a lot of underscores
says does stockfish blunder no a blunder
in a traditional sense is a mon mental
mistake stockfish doesn't blunder
anywhere near the traditional sense but
at times it will place a piece on a
certain square and then not realize that
actually 20 moves down the line that
piece is not supposed to be positioned
there and all of a sudden it's too late
to defend itself stockfish has lost not
to humans it's lost to other Bots like
Leela Komodo or torch but it definitely
doesn't blunder like we do at osen
domita asks how does chess notation work
I'm going to bite someone no need for
physical assault it is quite simple if I
was going to play a chess game right now
I would play Pawn to D4 and the way you
write that down is just the square that
the pawn moved to you don't have to
write P so it's kind of shorthand so you
would write
D4 and that is what that would look like
and then your opponent would let's say
play E6 Pawn to E6 you would write
E6 and it would be D4 E6 White made
their first move and black made their
first move C4 so you would write C4 now
let's say your opponent developed a
knight they played Knight to F6 K is
king So Knight is n Knight F6 so it
would be n F6 there's some moments where
two pieces can actually move to the same
square for example in this position both
of Black's Knights can go to D7 so if
this Knight went to D7 it started on B
so Knight B
D7 and if this Knight went to D7 it
would be Knight F to D7 bonus what if
both Knights were on the exact same file
now Knight bd7 is the same exact thing
so their only differentiator is what
rank they're on so Knight 8 D7 Knight 6
D7 you only ever really need to do this
with knights and Rooks because the
Bishops can never go to the same square
cuz they go in opposite colors at Aiden
bore says chess prodigies are so crazy
to me how are you 7 years old and
beating people who spent 60 years of
their lives learning chess that's
actually the beautiful thing about Chess
it's a Timeless game and Incredibly
children and adults learn chess in
vastly different ways people who start
chess at a very young age have a chance
of getting to a much higher sealing
overall in their chess careers that's
why you'll see at a local chess
tournament 7-year-old playing a
60-year-old I played a chess tournament
in St Louis A couple of years ago and I
played the number four number two and
number one ranked 11year olds in America
and I only scored 50% at advv Universe
asks what is the single piece of Chess
advice that help you improve the most
the biggest piece of advice that I give
to kids or adults trying to learn this
game is to completely disconnect your
ego from this learning experience be
prepared to lose a lot there is no other
way to get better at chess you will
probably lose three out of every four
games that you play but there are four
to five things that you can learn in
each of those games if you are unable to
do that because it makes you angry or
upset or frustrated then you are never
going to get better at chess at im a
Leisa says hey what is the pricee take
for this Chess World Cup so the prize
take for this year's World Cup in 2023
Was Won by Magnus Carlson and it was
estimated to be something like
$110,000 the Chess World Cup is actually
different than than the World Chess
Championship the World Cup is a knockout
tournament that happens every two years
in chess it starts with 128 players and
ends with two at Rome with John asks how
is chess boxing a thing chess boxing is
a sport that combines chess and boxing
shockingly and essentially all it is is
a game of chess with a person and then
you pause the game and you box for a
round and then you finish the chess game
from the point it was started and then
you keep going until one person either
wins in the chess or knocks the other
out it's a fascinating Sport and it
wasn't too popular until 2022 when lwig
massive YouTuber actually put on the
chess boxing event I was a part of it I
was a commentator I thought I was going
to fight but I am a little bit too
scared of getting punched in the face at
R syn asks I still can't wrap around the
concept of speed chess how can you
decide to move under a second form a
strat and it usually lasts under a
minute the amount of brain cells you use
in this there no brain cells at all the
average really good chess player
probably doesn't know how to make toast
there is no correlation between chess
and intelligence except in my case
listen speed chess is all pattern
recognition if you've seen it before
it's not always going to be a one to one
but you're going to have enough
experience that you know what parts go
where these people can do it in 2 3
seconds speed chess is my favorite type
of chess if I have to get slowed down
then that's where I really struggle at
sabba Osman Kazi asks where did chess
come from allegedly around 600 AD in
India it was called chaturanga and back
then the rules were slightly different
but that apparently is the first
earliest recorded instance of Chess and
I would know I was there at bison booze
asks did chess ever change its rules I
mean for a game that old they must have
made a few balanc patches over the years
there have been very very few changes to
the game of chess there are things
called variants where they let's say
Shuffle the back row of pieces and now
that's called chess 960 or giveaway
where you try to lose all of your pieces
and so on and so forth and the last time
there was really any major update is
when they instituted on pessant at
renquan asks bro what is on pant what
the hell I just found out about this
rule on pant in chess is a rule that
came out I don't know something like 200
years ago and essentially all it is your
Pawn has crossed the center line and
your opponent makes a pawn move and
stands side by side with your Pawn they
have to move two squares for this move
and this move only you can take that
pawn diagonally behind it the only way
you can on pan is if a pawn moves two
squares for this turn you cannot do that
if it was another piece if your opponent
just mve their Knight to that square you
cannot on pant a knight you would get
punched in the face at MZ Slayer one
asks chess lovers what do you consider
to be the most famous move in chess
history 1972 Bobby fiser Boris basy
World Chess Championship United States
versus Soviet Union Cold War era they
begin the match and toward the end game
Fischer captured a pawn and got his
Bishop trapped in one move it was an
oversight that let's say an amateur
player wouldn't even make it was just a
complete just mental slip for a move
Fischer captured a pawn in the corner of
the board essentially and all spasy had
to do was move his Pawn one square and
his Bishop had no way out it was a
completely inexplicable mistake fiser
had not made a mistake like that in his
entire career and he never made a
mistake like that ever again Bobby fiser
went on to lose that game but a world
championship match is played over many
games and even though he lost that first
one in this completely ridiculous
fashion he actually went on to dominate
and win the match at cozy Kion asks why
do chess players resign instead of
taking the loss people at the highest
level resign when they know they're
going to lose and they know that their
opponent knows how to beat them most of
you watching this should not resign
because you never know stalemate is
possible at the end of a game Running
Out of Time by accident Wi-Fi
disconnecting to resign you would either
tip over your king which is the dramatic
way to do it you would click a button on
chess.com if you were playing or you'll
see Grand Masters often times just pause
the clock and I would extend my hand to
my opponent to shake it which is just a
silent way of saying I Surrender at cor
questions 4 says what is the greatest
chess match ever the best chess match
which took a long period of time you
probably have to look at 1984 Gary
Kasparov and anat kpov and back then it
was decided by the first person to win
six games kpov got to a 5 nothing lead
and then Kasparov did not lose and he
defended defended defended he fought to
make it 53 with like 30 draws in the
middle and the match basically had to be
called off due to health concerns it was
like two months of playing chess against
each other I would never survive so
that's all the questions we have for you
today I just want to say a big thank you
to all of you for watching chess playing
chess supporting chess in any way shape
or form until next time thank you for
watching chess
[Music]
support